[Music]
ho ho ho
marvel fans here you are just in time
for the christmas holidays we have
something special planned for you in
today's news episode and that is a short
and crisp preview of the soon to begin
phase 4 of the mcu before things really
kick off with one division in january
marvel will deliver a series called
marvel studios
legends according to the official
announcement the focus will be mainly on
recapping the most epic and iconic
moments
in mcu history in doing so each episode
is set to center on different characters
starting with vision and wanda maximoff
even though not a lot has been known
about it we don't assume that we will be
presented with a mere clip compilation
perhaps we'll learn a bit more about the
backstories and motifs of the individual
characters
in any case you'll be able to find out
more on disney plus starting january 8th
2021 the official start of phase 4 will
be highlighted by the series
one division in a few weeks as to
content it is about the two heroes
vision and wanda
also known as scarlet witch who live an
idealized suburban life
the story takes place after the
happenings of avengers endgame which may
seem odd considering the events of
endgame and infinity war
so if you haven't seen the two movies
yet you should urgently do so before
watching the series
the series is directed by matt shackman
while the original actors elizabeth
olsen and paul bettany return to their
roles
one division is set to launch on disney
plus on january 15
2021 in march the story is going to
continue with
the falcon and the winter soldier here
the story of sam wilson and bucky barnes
is being resumed after steve rogers has
officially retired
so now they have to fight against the
world's evil without captain america's
help and in this case it bears the name
baron zemo the powerful villain will
certainly stretch the two heroes to the
limit which is why solo efforts are not
an option the entire project is directed
by kerry skoglund while the three actors
anthony mackie sebastian stan and daniel
bruil naturally return to their old
familiar roles
if you want to get a first glimpse you
can watch the newly released first
trailer on
our channel the official release date is
march 19th
2021 the first movie of phase four
is in the early summer of 2021 and will
be called
black widow most recently natasha
romanov alias black widow appeared in
avengers ant game
the unresolved questions left by her
appearance in the marvel story will then
be answered in this standalone film
this will include a reunion with other
black widows however
an encounter with the captain america
counterpart greg guardian is also said
to be coming up
shedding light on the past of the
russian top spy scarlett johansson
florence pew
and david harbour are cast in the lead
roles while kate shortland directs the
film
are you looking forward to the first mcu
movie of phase 4
may 7th 2021 will finally be the big day
the series loki with tom hiddleston and
on wilson is also planned for may 2021
in six episodes everything will revolve
around thor's brother who travels
through different timelines
to his time travels he changes the
course of human history quite
dramatically
in the process he stirs up quite a bit
of chaos and quickly has to bother with
the time variance agency or tva for
short
an exact release date in may is not yet
known but as soon as it is
we'll of course let you know in our
weekly news
next up is changshi and the legends of
the 10 rings
this particular movie is about the
adventures of changshi the master of
kung fu and it is indeed the first
of the mcu to feature an asian main
character
xiangxi is actually the son of the
villain fu manchu who instructs him in
martial arts
eventually however he decides not to
follow in his father's footsteps and
becomes a hero
instead of a villain of course as the
title suggests the mysterious tan rings
organization
also plays a major role by the way the
organization was first present in the
first
iron man movie when they kidnapped tony
stark starring simul you
tony chi wai yang and aquafina the
release date is july 9th
2021 another new addition to the mcu is
the fully animated
what if series it covers many different
alternate timelines of well-known
storylines
for instance what if loki's plan had
worked out in thor
or what if captain america had turned
into a zombie we are definitely excited
to see a lot of
peculiar crazy scenarios that we
otherwise would have never seen in the
mcu
the series will be coming to disney plus
in the summer of 2021
after the avengers made their last
glorious appearance on phase 3
a new collective is now entering phase 4
of the mcu
namely the eternals in short there are
race of immortal beings who step
seeker's presence on earth dates backs
countless years however tragedy forces
them to step out of the shadows
and fight against their greatest enemies
the deviants
the mix of top-notch cast and the
exciting storyline is sure to lure many
fans to the front of the screens
the expected start date is scheduled for
november 5th 2021
the friendly spider from the
neighborhood will also return next year
after a brilliant finale in spider-man
far from home
plenty of things will change in the
upcoming spider-man 3.
to begin with there's the spectacular
reunion of the first two spider-man toby
maguire and andrew garfield with tom
holland but major supporting characters
are also expected to return in this
multiverse blockbuster
including kirsten dunst as mary jane
watson jamie foxx as villain electro
alfred molina as doc ock
and charlie cox as daredevil from the
netflix series of the same name
it is not yet clear in what way the
appearance of the familiar faces will
take place
but we are definitely looking forward to
the release of the live-action version
of the legendary spider-man meme on
december 17
2021 also planned for
2021 is a hawkeye series set after the
events of avengers
end game clint barton who will again be
played by jeremy renner
gets accustomed to his new life as a
ronin and henceforth to act as a mentor
for the young kate bishop
played by haley steinfeld first
impressions could be gathered from
pictures of the shooting in a new york
subway station
it has been considered certain ever
since that steinfeld will actually slip
into the role of cape bishop are you
already excited about the long-awaited
hawkeye series
it is expected to release in the second
half of 2021
the focus of the next series scheduled
for 2021 is kamala khan
16 year old american with pakistani
ancestry this straight a student is not
only an avid video game fan but also the
first muslim marvel heroine to get her
own movie more or less by chance
she then discovers her superpowers which
come mainly with the sheer endless
stretching ability of her extremities
from then on just like a role model
captain marvel she provides law and
order in jersey city
the fourth spin-off of the thor series
is called love and thunder and is
scheduled for release in 2022
the plot is based on the mighty thor
comic and thus also features a female
thor
jane foster played by natalie portman
after thor had left the scene with
guardians at the end of avengers endgame
many fans are also eager to know what
happens next with him
by february 11th 2022 you will be more
in the know about this
after thor we continue with a sequel to
doctor strange from
2016. as the title implies we can
probably expect a huge expansion of the
mcu
unusual for an mcu movie is especially
the idea to conceive the film as a kind
of
horror movie primarily responsible for
this is sam raimi
in front of the camera will be seen
among others benedict cumberbatch as
doctor strange elizabeth olsen as wanda
and chewie jellyfor as baron mordo the
start day so far has been set for march
25th
2022 in conclusion we present you two
undated series from phase four
she-hulk and moon knight the first
mansion series explores the life of
bruce banner's cousin jennifer walters
as a female hulk
while the rather dark moon knight series
is about the former mercenary who holds
multiple personalities
and is steeped in the powers of an
egyptian deity both series don't have a
fixed relay state as of yet but as soon
as that changes
we will inform you as always so that's
it already with the upcoming projects
from phase 4 of the mcu
which movie or series are you most
looking forward to
feel free to write it down in the
comments
[Music]
foreign